[Música]
y hay virus es que están también en la
parte Silvestre y en la parte de la
población humana sabemos que es en este
viruses que debemos desarrollar
estrategia de vigilancia y de prevención
porque se puede desarrollar como una
cepa un poco más virulente Y entonces
que se puede dar una epidemia
[Música]
es lo que pretende este proyecto es
tener este conocimiento pues para poder
predecir si es posible futuras pandemias
que es lo que nos acaba de pasar
recientemente con el conocimiento de
cuáles son los virus que están
circulando Pues nosotros poder dar algún
mapa de riesgo de estas zonas y pues
poner los focos rojos donde deben de
estar
[Música]
la estrategia de Educación Ambiental
tiene diversos públicos meta no entonces
dentro de esos públicos meta Por
supuesto que están las comunidades
locales y los pueblos indígenas no de de
la Península de Yucatán entonces para
trabajar con ellos es muy importante
trabajar desde una forma participativa
Entonces se hacen talleres de
sensibilización y talleres también de
para identificar las problemáticas
socioambientales
[Música]